[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock in the UK 1am here in
Turkey is the number known killed by
these earthquakes Rises past seven
thousand
[Music]
the desperate families digging for loved
ones through the rubble and pleading for
help which Never Comes
so many people who feel they're not
getting the help that they need
our special correspondencies and hears
the pain as the World Health
Organization warns the final number of
deaths could triple
there are though incredible escapes
including for this little girl pulled to
Safety in Syria
as turkey as president declares a state
of emergency We join one of the aid
flights arriving in the country
what would your message be I said where
are you
and the message to the authorities from
a man far from home I joined armett from
South Wales trying to reach his family
also on Sky News at 10 tonight
Untouchable no more the serial rapist
police officer condemned as monstrous by
a judge and jailed for at least 30 years
building up his team the prime
minister's mini cabinet reshuffled as he
makes energy security a priority
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from around 10 40.
[Music]
good evening then from Eartha in South
Eastern Turkey more than 7 300 people
are now known to have died in the
earthquakes which hit here yesterday
that is a staggering total but there was
a warning today that the final figure
could be more than twenty thousand and
while Aid flights as well as rescue
teams are starting to arrive here
tonight the message we heard loud and
clear was that people are not receiving
enough government help
the first 7.8 magnitude earthquake hit
Southeastern turkey just after 4 15 a.m
yesterday morning after hundreds of
aftershocks a magnitude 7.5 earthquake
struck a neighboring Province just over
nine hours later tonight we'll hear not
just from here in urfa but also from our
International correspondent John Sparks
who is in osmania
but first our special correspondent Alex
Crawford reports from antakia and are
warning her report shows the attempt to
resuscitate a child who sadly died
they're using bits of rubble
whatever they can get their hands on to
reach those buried
can anyone hear me she's shouting
they can hear sounds
so they keep calling and listening for
the loved ones who lived here
[Music]
but they've come with little more than
courage and a great deal of Hope
and their tools make barely any impact
on an eight-story building now all on
the ground floor
relatives look on sick with worry
and the bubbling anger growing inside
[Music]
no support yet from the government
we have now 40 hours no one cup yes
nobody nobody are here to touch this I
understand from the 40 hour I am the one
waiting here for 40 hours no one car is
game an area here to touch now we are
dying here no it's dying okay just
buying
they stand in huddles weeping and find
Comfort by talking to the trapped
children they may never see again
on yard
be strong then he is she's saying to him
be strong we are here
the fury is real and raw the
government's not here she's shouting
enough enough enough
this city which hugs the Syrian border
appears to be one of the worst hit it's
home to a huge number of Syrian refugees
who fled the war to safety here and the
hatai mayor is from the main opposition
party stoking suspicions that this may
have contributed to the little Aid
evident here
we saw residents helping themselves to
food and supplies from a supermarket
which had been broken into but also saw
a television being carted away
it's because we're hungry one man told
us
inspiration is haunting this city
for the love of God please help us she
begs us God I'm waiting for help she
says
her husband's trapped upstairs and
they're flat and has poor sight please I
expect help from my government
there's so many people who feel they're
not getting the help that they need
not one person he tells us we haven't
seen a single soul here
we don't even have any water to drink or
even have any bread to eat she goes on
my daughter's in there with her two kids
another man tells us they've died in
that house
there are moments of sheer Joy a young
baby is pulled out
after so many hours she is a real living
miracle
she's too young to remember what
happened but her family will remind her
she's one who beat the odds on turkey's
terrible day of earthquakes
the baby's mother has somehow kept her
alive and she too has been found they're
both badly dehydrated and the young mum
looks traumatized
this has been a terrifying experience
for them all
there are questions about how well
prepared they were here for a disaster
long predicted to happen but every time
someone is coats to safety and guided
down the piles of broken concrete which
were once their homes it inspires The
Rescuers to keep on going
but there are far more suffering far too
many mothers consumed by grief as the
wafer than hoped they were clinging onto
finally disappears
The Rescuers don't give up though there
are frantic efforts to try to
resuscitate her boy they try and they
keep on trying
this is a young life they cannot save
this region is probably uniquely
ill-equipped to cope with a natural
disaster of this scale and the heartache
and grief is going to grow over the next
few days and weeks
and Alex has moved to the city of adarna
tonight and Alex harrowing scenes today
and this constant refrain that people
are not getting the help they need
yeah and it's not just constant it's
repetitive the entire time that we were
there we were surrounded by people
constantly followed by people angry
people sad people begging us for help
begging us to to bring help and no
apparent concerted coordinated really
big effort which they desperately need
there to try to to help the people it's
not just rescuing those who are trapped
and many many people there believe that
they have got relatives who they're
still talking to and who they can hear
and who they can hear making sounds if
not crying out to them it's not just
them it's the people who've been left
homeless who need shelter who they don't
have water they don't have power they
don't have anywhere to stay and this is
the second night in near freezing
temperatures hospitals have come down in
that area we saw at least one that had
just crushed down at the top floor
top floors that all landed on the the
bottom floors so they are in desperate
need and one of the the people told us
there's looting everywhere and we don't
even blame them because people need to
eat and they need to drink so not even
the very basic facilities are being
extended to them at the moment
so thank you very much indeed
now one of the features of This Disaster
is the huge size of the area affected
here in Turkey alone it's more than a
hundred thousand square kilometers
that's significantly larger than
Scotland we saw Alex Crawford's report
from the city of antakia there and 80
miles north of it in ozamania our
International correspondent John Sparks
witnessed a very similar story of rarely
realized hope
in a small corner of the city of osmania
the sound of heavy machinery fills the
air
their metal Scoops moving Rubble as the
members of a rescue team searched the
concrete slabs looking for signs of life
then a call goes out
[Music]
All Quiet on the site and the frenzied
sound of digging swiftly ends
can you hear me tap on the side of the
wall
[Music]
but these desperate questions go
unanswered
there are hundreds of people here but it
is
silent
but they haven't heard anything
there's nothing
five apartment blocks occupied the area
the residents asleep when the earthquake
struck and it seems unlikely that anyone
survived
it looks like a lot of people lived here
foreign
not yet
Hope was fading and the Outlook bleak
we listened to the anguish tone of those
looking on
good morning
yesterday the governor came here said
this woman but he does nothing there are
young children in these buildings but
they do nothing
a couple of hundred meters away near the
City Central Square we found a similar
scene
another human tragedy
there was a man staring at a pile of
rubble he said he was waiting for his
brother the only thing he could do do
you think it's possible that your
brother is is still alive
up to 15 people are missing no one's
really sure
but this man knows his father is here he
just found his trousers
is it possible that your father could
survive this
use this exam
s
the local highways are clogged
the supplies and the Specialists stuck
in traffic and many Regional roads are
now impossible
but they are desperately needed in this
city of debris
John Sparks Sky News in osmania
well the victims of the earthquakes
across the border in Syria are dealing
with uh not just this natural disaster
but also the ongoing impact of War the
British government has condemned the
Syrian authorities for what it said was
an attack on an opposition-held town in
the immediate aftermath of the quakes
there were stories of Hope though in
Syria too this report from our Middle
East correspondent Aleister bunkel
includes pictures of the rescue of a
young baby though sadly found next to
the body
of one of the victims
this is why there is still some hope
a little girl called North is gently
pulled out from the remains of her home
in Northwest Syria The Rescuers
encouraged her to talk to her father who
is standing nearby waiting to hug his
daughter
of course these moments of Hope are
vastly outnumbered by the discovery of
dead bodies they are finding more and
more every hour
the Syrian white helmets are working
around the clock and with little
International Help
they must feel that the world has
forgotten about them but Aid agencies
haven't reached the area yet simply
because they just haven't been able to
negotiate a way across the one border
crossing that is currently open
[Music]
this is Aleppo before the war it used to
be Syria's commercial hub then it became
the center of intense fighting now it
looks like this
the city is under Syrian regime control
and present Assad's government has asked
for international Aid
a Russian cargo plane landed in Syria
today but after years of defying the
West Assad might now be forced to accept
their help
we need heavy equipment ambulances and
firefighting Vehicles we don't have fire
fighting vehicles to put out fires we
don't have heavy equipment to conduct
rescue operations there are a lot of
issues surfacing now due to the
sanctions sanctions against the Syrian
people
in another Syrian Town another moment of
relief at first this young child appears
to be lifeless
and then
[Music]
they carefully scrape away the rubble
and pull him free coughing from the dust
in his throat
the body of a woman lies next to the
baby
the difference between life and death
was only a matter of inches Alistair
bunkel Sky News
obviously
as we saw analysters report their
rescues are succeeding in freeing some
of the victims they're using basic
equipment in their bare hands they're
more sophisticated help is now on the
way our data and forensics correspondent
Tom Cheshire has been looking at the
rescue effort
this is a gigantic search and rescue
operation because it is a gigantic
search area spanning two countries but
just to show how far this has reached
Aleppo is a long way away from the
epicenter but we can still take a look
at the damage that's been happening
there and how they're trying to find
people in the rubble I mean this is some
of the scenes we've seen it does look
fairly ad hoc it is quite ad hoc but
there's still a reason behind this you
have the bulldozer over here people on
top right there the Bulldogs are not
getting involved in that role but just
in case there are people inside instead
looking through by hand but there are
different techniques available this is
also from Syria an opposition control
part of Surya and the white helmets at
work who of course have a lot of
experience bringing people out from
underneath buildings now they're taking
a generator there but also an important
bit of Kit which will really really help
with this we'll just show you there now
I think you'll be able to see it that
just down here
it's a bit of hydraulics from a German
company it's portable and we'll see how
useful that is if we go on in this video
this is a really difficult rescue okay
you can see how tight it is uh how heavy
all this stuff is and there's not much
you could do by hand but with this bit
of Kit and we can show you here here you
are you can see it at work we'll just
magnify that so you can see it a bit
better that means you can start chomping
through that concrete really which makes
a lot of difference now more kit is on
the way especially from a broad 70
countries pledging assistance this is
Philippines search and rescue from there
this is advice for looking there's a
camera at the end of that pole you put
it into the rubble and you can try and
find people and communicate with them
but all sorts of gear this is posted by
Italian firefighters huge Concrete
Cutters all sorts of hydraulics this is
a fan for trying to ventilate people in
smaller places and you've also got other
things like the bolt cutters coming in
now despite all this Tech and there are
boxes and boxes of it all being loaded
taken to Turkey and Syria this is
another very important part of this
rescue dogs sniffer dogs vital even
though they're not high-tech vital for
finding people uh stuck in the rubble
now they're on their way now they will
be trying to gather as quickly as
possible because the first one to three
days after an earthquake after any
disaster what known as the golden period
for saving lives Wednesday is day three
since the earthquake so they'll be
rushing to get there as quickly as
possible
but it's not just the physical health
that is being offered to the people of
turkey tonight and the rescue effort my
colleague yusra elberger joined a flight
from Qatar which has offered more than
100 tons of tents and Food Supplies she
reports now on the aid effort
an international response to an
international disaster Qatar one of
turkey's closest allies has opened an
air bridge to deliver Aid
the humanitarian Aid which exceeded a
hundred tons contained tents Food
Supplies blankets and cleaning
detergents for the affected people
they're also adding manpower to rescue
efforts and this military plane is
flying straight into the earthquake's
epicenter gaziantep
we're on our way to Turkey on a relief
flight that is transporting roughly
military personnel to the country to set
up a base there and help with emergency
response
turkey's president erdogan made an
international appeal soon after disaster
struck and said 70 countries pledged to
help
we declare the ten provinces beset by
the earthquakes to be a disaster area
affecting General Life by the power
conferred on us by article 119 of the
Constitution we have decided to declare
a state of emergency support is now
flooding in from all over the world from
Britain and France to South Korea and
Russia
but freezing temperatures and
aftershocks have made this an endless
nightmare with buildings crumbling into
streets and many still buried under
Rubble
International solidarity is key to
addressing this catastrophe but in
practice or only scratch the surface
Sky News gazian tap
well the impact of the earthquakes here
is again reflected in tomorrow's papers
which we'll be reviewing a little later
than usual tonight at 10 40. this is
what the eye has on its front page the
headline race to find quake survivors
well I'll be back before that press
preview with the story of one man I met
here today searching for his family but
for now Emma at Sky News Center has the
rest of the day's news
mark thank you very much a former police
officer and serial rapist behaved like
he was Untouchable the judge told him
today David Carrick was sentenced to a
minimum of 30 years in jail after taking
monstrous advantage of the power of his
position the commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police were Carrick served
for two decades said he'd survived
because of systemic failings our crime
correspondent Martin brunt reports five
o'clock in the morning PC David Carrick
dragged from his bed and arrested police
officers right David do you want me to
come make it like this no just
understand you're under arrest okay just
explain to us what do you need like this
can one of my colleagues go and get you
stuff yeah more than a year later
Carrick admitted 49 sex crimes against
12 women
Carrick arrived at court to be sentenced
an obvious Target for those who campaign
against male violence behind a public
appearance of propriety and
trustworthiness
you took monstrous advantage of women
drawn into intimate relationships with
you
carrick's fate was broadcast live he was
damned by the judge's words the malign
influence of men like you in positions
of power stands in the way of a
revolution of women's dignity
you behaved as if you were untouchable
you are bold and at times Relentless
trusting
that no victim would overcome her shame
and fear to report to you
some victims did report Carrick but no
action was taken against him he kept his
job while he was harassing assaulting
and raping women
there was another apology from carrick's
old boss there are systemic failings in
this case we had opportunities where
where
warning signs were seen by the Met
reports allegations
and we didn't follow through on those
and that's why he was still a police
officer when he shouldn't have been
Carrick was jailed for Life a minimum 30
years before any chance of parole
several of the women Carrick attacked
were in court to see him jailed police
and prosecutors praised The Bravery of
carrick's victims but they believe there
are more they urged them to come forward
some already have
Carrick left to begin his sentence ahead
of him said the judge a difficult time
in custody for many years Martin brunt
Sky News at Southern Crown Court
the father of a morbidly obese teenager
was found guilty of her manslaughter
through gross negligence today Kaylee
tipford weighed nearly 23 Stone when she
was found dead at her family home in
Paris in 2020 Sky's Katarina vitotsi has
our report and a warning it does contain
images of the conditions that Kaylee was
found in
on the morning of October 10 2020 Kaylee
tipford wouldn't wake up
what you're about to hear is the 999
call between an ambulance operator and
Kaylee's father Alan tipford who was in
the family home in Newtown Wales
then
and are you able to wait here okay
I need you to get her onto the floor
there can you lay a slap on your back on
the floor
that can help you
do we navigate
together onto the floor
this is the bed of Kaylee titford when
paramedics arrived Kaylee was already
dead
still lying on her bed surrounded by
rubbish junk food cartons and
incontinence pads stained with urine
her father told police because of covert
lockdowns they hadn't taken their
daughter to a doctor
and Kaylee hadn't returned to school
after it reopened
the teen described by her teachers as
Lively and fiercely independent despite
her disability was more than 22 stone at
the time of her death
Pathologists say she died from
complications linked to her obesity
Kaylee titford's mother Sarah Lloyd
Jones had already pleaded guilty to her
manslaughter due to gross negligence but
Kaylee's father Alan tetford denied that
same charge saying that especially as
his daughter got older her care was the
responsibility of her mother
but a jury found Alan tetford guilty of
manslaughter by gross neglect the scale
of neglect was significant
truly shocking the neglect had clearly
been ongoing for a prolonged period of
time
a Child Services review has been
launched into how a vulnerable girl came
to die in conditions described as unfit
for an animal
Catherine avatoxy Sky News Paris Wales
detectors investigating The
Disappearance of Nicola bully say they
are fully open to new information but
remain convinced that she fell into the
Rhythm the 45 year old was last seen
walking her dog in St Michael's on wire
in Lancashire 11 days ago superintendent
Sally Riley told reporters there were no
suspicious element to the investigation
so far it does remain our belief
that Nicola sadly fell into the river
and that this is a missing person
inquiry
and it is important to stress that any
information that comes in
that indicates otherwise is being
checked out all the time
and negated as each inquiry comes up
we're not closed in any way to any
particular line of inquiry and we remain
genuinely open to that
detectives investigating the deaths of
private school head teacher Emma
Patterson and her seven-year-old
daughter Letty say they're treating it
as a potential murder suicide both were
found in the grounds of Epsom College in
the early hours of Sunday morning
alongside the body of her husband George
BP has announced that its underlying
profit more than doubled to a record 23
billion pounds last year it follows
record profits for its rival shell on
the back of surging Energy prices driven
by Russia's invasion of Ukraine
mushy sennak shoveled his cabinet pack
today in a limited way and perhaps more
fundamentally created new departments
for energy security and science the key
political announcements was the
appointment of Greg hands as the new
conservative party chair after Nadeem
sahari's resignation Grant shaps moves
from business secretary to become the
new secretary of state for energy
security and Net Zero Cami badnock now
leads the joint department for business
and trade Michelle donland becomes
Secretary of State for science
Innovation and Technology Lucy Fraser
replaces her as the Secretary of State
for culture media and Sport and Lee
Anderson the Ashfield MP who's become
one of the most outspoken red wall back
benchers has been appointed Deputy
chairman ah Deputy political editor Sam
Coates reports
the new chairman of the conservative
party eager to stress he's very
different to the last one are your taxes
good morning they most definitely are
good morning how are you
coming of course we will we can and we
will a hopeful message for a party in
need of a big turnaround Greg hands
replacing the sacked Nadine zahawi the
first appointment of Rishi sunak's first
proper reshuffle but even for those
involved this is hardly a dramatic
overhaul
that's a bit of reshuffle few fresh
faces and one key Survivor Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Raab under
investigation for bullying keeps his job
are you surprised you're still there Mr
Rob one more going cabinet but this
Shuffle more about changing roles than
Changing Faces the Prime Minister
creating four new Whitehall departments
revealing where he thinks the government
isn't delivering
Grant shaft in charge of a new
department for energy security and Net
Zero there's the latest in a growing
list of personal priorities for the
Prime Minister the changes to government
I've announced today will help us
deliver on those promises for the
British people particularly the creation
of a brand new the first of its kind
department for energy security and Net
Zero so we can really focus on that
issue bring down people's energy bills
energy security delivered by a cabinet
minister on his third job in four months
serving alongside the six business
secretaries since the last general
election in 2019. so as we watch
familiar cabinet names slot into new
government job titles it's become clear
Rishi sunak decided that he was going to
undertake a pretty major restructuring
underneath the Bonnet of the government
and while he says that that's needed to
help deliver the people's priorities the
danger is that changing the way things
work just slows up his ability to get
things done
MP's worried the times the thing this
government doesn't have Sam Coates Sky
News Westminster
foreign
well the scale of a disaster like this
can sometimes feel almost
dehumanizing it's in individual stories
that the true tragedy can hit home Ahmed
illness doesn't even live in Turkey his
home is in South Wales but today I met
him trying to reach his family and this
is what happened next
in a country in despair I'm at yilnaz is
a Broken Man
we came across him amid the chaos of one
of the few functioning airports here
having made the journey from South Wales
he is desperately trying to find a way
to reach the Mountain Village he grew up
in I mean it's completely collapsed this
is what is left of his brother Ali's
house Ali is dead his wife seriously
injured and two of his children are
missing in the rubble
we decide to take him or at least to get
as close as we can
halfway there he gets a call from his
surviving niece to say no one is coming
to help them Ahmed cannot bear it
once we're up in the mountains it is not
an easy Journey
we finally reached the village the
damage the reality of it all
[Music]
and for Ahmet reunited with his sister
fatter the uncontrollable grief
foreign
[Music]
that they are looking for now
it is heartbreaking
tells me it was a house full of joy and
love and now his family is destroyed
so Ahmed just tell me when you see this
what goes through your mind
unbelievable
I never see this I am very sharp
I never see this happen before my left
never
he says the locals want to know where
the government help is the truth is the
government is overwhelmed
what would your message be I said where
are you
we need the people accommodation with
everybody's freezing they've been only
locals people they count neighbors or
friends they will try Harbor where is
the government
in these remote snowy Villages they will
have a long wait
I'm very sorry for your loss yeah very
sorry
I can't believe
one man facing the enormity of it all in
this country of countless tragedies
and uh we do have
um well some optimistic news uh there
are reports and indeed pictures tonight
of someone being rescued from the rubble
this I'm told is in the city of marash
and it is a rare success today there
haven't been many rescues it is bitterly
cold here and this is not often
happening but here in marash is the
rescue of someone
this evening
and uh behind me here I should say that
the searching uh goes on they live in
Hope here as well that they will find
someone uh alive but I have to say uh in
the last hour or so all they've been
bringing out are bodies
from here in southern turkey it is back
to Emma in London